Yeah, I be talking on the toilet.
It's fun. It's better talking to the boys
than these raggedy-ass girls all the time.
Hey, bruh.
-Hello?
-Hello!
-Who's this?
What are you doing?
I had just got here from juvenile hall
and so, I didn't know anything
about toilet talking or any of that.
My bunkie was like,
"There's some guys banging on our line."
-Hello?
-What are you talking about?
-Hello.
-People were talking into the toilet?
-Like, really?
-Yeah?
I miss you!
So, to talk on the toilet bowl,
you have to bail out.
You take all the water out,
dump it in the sink.
She bailed the toilet out and knocked,
and somebody answered.
I was like, "Oh my God,
what is happening here?"
Everybody has their own knock,
because there's people
on the eighth floor, on the sixth floor,
there's people on the fifth floor.
You can even talk to the boys
on the fourth floor.
You can barely hear them,
it's very quiet.
I hear you, motherfucker.
Is there any bitches on the line?
[female inmate] I've been trying to get
bitches on the line for a minute!
And then you can, like,
create a relationship.
I've been missing you all my life.
He was hella hot,
and I was like, "Ooh, okay.
Talk to me."
This is my microphone. Hello?
Oh, hello?
I was like, "Oh, my gosh,
this is so cool.
It's like having a cell phone!"
Hey, you hear me?
Who is this?
-It's Graham.
-I'm on six.
[female inmate] Are you black or brown?
Nah, I'm a white boy.
[male inmate] I'm trying to go out
of my way to get ahold of somebody.
-Whatcha want me to tell her?
-I don't know who figured it out,
but whoever first did it was a genius,
'cause that's real science, for real.
[male inmate]
Tell him to get on the phone tomorrow.
All right.
[inmate] Okay, later.
He flushed, so he hung up the phone, so...
That's it.